how you doing tonight hi you have
driver's license yeah my reg are you
stilling on Lake monitoring yeah is a uh
vehicle register to you um it's register
to my dad to your dad you want my
registration yes you anything
else I'm so sorry what is my register
I know I have it but I just have it's a
piece of paper that uh your sticker
would come on it is for the vehicle
registration
mine wait I think this is
it oh that's some kind of service
record I know I have it I've just never
used it so I'm so sorry is that your
insurance this this
one's is my
insurance it
says wait I found it I found it this
one sorry that is
my all right and you said you had your
insurance I I
am
is this it it says Insurance
identification
card that'll be not all right um you
know why you got pulled
over no all right when you uh entered on
oh no when you entered onto the uh arm
ramp all right there's two lanes and
then you had the merge lane you were in
a merge lane all right you made one lane
change and then another Lane change you
never even used the turn signal when you
cut a car off in the first Lane okay all
right did you not see that car
um no no no no in the merge L hi no not
in the merge L all right where are you
heading to I haveit to my
house to go to my house we just left the
app okay how old are you I'm 18 18 all
right yeah is uh everything go to your
license no one paay tickets no
suspensions or anything um I have I have
a ticket that I haven't paid yet but
it's not suspended it's not it was like
literally like um a week ago cuz I was
speeding I was speeding I will at that
um I was going like 20 over but or maybe
15 let me not say 20 let me take this
but the but the license is Bid the
license is Bid all right just hang tight
here one second all right good you're
good all right Avery
yes do you have any medical conditions
that affect your ability to drive this
car no have you taken any prescription
medications control have you had any
legal drugs including
marijuana all right how much alcohol
have you had
tonight huh I have none you had
none
okay how much alcohol have you had
tonight
none I live
in and that's where we were on um what's
her address
um I know what's
my
it's I'm going to my dad's house my
parents are divorced um I was
at what is her
name it's not monary
it's
my mom
lives she
lives and they're like Rue and
white
um is there a reason that I would smell
an odor of unknown alcoholic beverage
coming
from no do you smell one all we have in
here is
Dr
that's literally it do you have any
problems with your eyes that AR
corrected by glasses
no not that I know of I'm pretty blind
when I read a couple of um books online
like on my phone that's it I've never
been like I've never been like eye
tested highspeed chases T we got a
unruly suspects I will kill that mother
me no do it stay in the bo I like Kink
dramatic DUI I'mma pass everything that
she trying to do and shocking body cam
footage hey get on the go get out the
ground law and crime presents body cam
the place for real raw and wild police
videos you should have seen it it was
good it's on body camera I'll show it to
you catch the action and subscribe to
our new YouTube channel
now
okay so you said your mom lives
she
lives and it's the tow
houses that's where my mom lives they
three three story tow houses they're
blue and
white thank you so much you are supped
to that that that's so you're coming
from your mom's house yes
my mom's name
is my last name is aone yeah my dad is
out of town him house sitting for him
because he has
animals all
right based on everything that I've seen
all right I want to request you perform
roadside task just to dispel any
suspicion that I had that you're driving
under influence tonight all right are
you one perform the road siid what is
that you want me to like get out it's uh
standardized field sobriety road siid
yeah yeah yeah all right can I take off
my um boots cuz I'm wearing yes we let's
do that over uh over here all right so
go ahead and you can step out now just
come back over
here if you want to go over here uh if
you want to stand right over here take
your boots off you don't need to take
the boots off right now or
they all right just do that while I kill
these lights real
quick I can do it in the booth if you
like all right the if you feel
comfortable uh I can do it in BO you're
good you're good all right what this
what I need you to do come back over
here we're not walking yet stand right
where my light is and just face me all
right do you have any problems with your
eyes that aren't corrected by the
glasses um I've never got tested to
glasses I don't know it's harder for me
to read books um I read a lot of books
and it's I see blurry but that's that's
about it do you have contacts in no I've
never been tesed for the eye all right
have you been in an accident today not
today you been to a doctor our dentist
today um have you been hit hit recently
no all right all right what I need you
to do we're going to put her feet
together arms on our side just like this
you're going to look straight ahead at
me all right what I'm going to do I'm
going to show you a light I'm going to
move that light left and right and up
and down I want you to follow that light
with your eyes only keep your head still
arms still and feet still all right you
understand you have any questions Ching
radio all right you see a light in front
of you yes what color is that light blue
all right I want you follow the blue
light with your eyes only okay
oh
for
[Music]
need
it's
rela you have any injuries or ailments
have an AFF your ability walk straight
line you feel comfortable walking in the
bo
for
a come down into this
in
use yellow line okay what you do is put
your left foot on the
line your left foot the toe just like
mine
arms in that position tell you to begin
I tell you to begin we're going to take
a series of nine steps forward turn
around take a series of nine steps back
each time we take a step we touch heel
to toe and we count I'll keep your arms
in by your side I'm going demon okay 1 2
3 4
L small steps and turn around take a
series nine steps back one 2 3 anytime
you feel like a lose balance step off
the line keep your balance don't fall
over wherever you stop counting at I
want you to pick right back up until the
nine steps are uh completed okay so four
five all the way
down all right do you have any questions
you want to start with my left foot left
foot onine L right foot in front of your
left nieps
forward we're going to turn around and
take series and nine steps
back
all right do you have any injuries or
ailments that would affect ability stand
on one
leg no but I might want to take off my
boots you can take off your boots that's
f up you leave
it you just want one boot off or you
want whatever I I would take both if
you're going to take one off that way
you're not uneven
right all right so we can stand where my
light at and just face me all right what
I need you to do is we're going to put
her feet together arms on by side just
like this you're going to remain in that
position till I tell you to begin all
right when I tell you to begin you can
pick up whatever leg you want if you
want to stand on your left stand on your
right does not matter all right um
whatever leg you're not going to stand
on you're going to raise it out in front
of you about 6 in okay right all right
so it's going to go straight out just
like this all right you're going to look
at your toe you're going to count out
1001 you don't have to do it yet 1001
100002 10003 and so on until I tell you
to stop if anytime you feel like you
lose your balance regain your balance
pick up where you stop counting at 1004
1005 1006 until I tell you to stop all
right do you have any questions all
right you
understand you understand all right you
can start when you want to 1 1 1 2 1 3
1,4 1 56
1 1008 1009 10,000 10,1
10,23 2014
2015 16 17 18,000
19,000 20,000
21,000 22,000
23,000,000
24,000 25,000
26,000 stop being relax um the other
ones we we're not going to be walking or
standing on leg so I don't know if you
want to uh put your boots back on or if
you want to stay like this it's
fine you know your left from your right
left right put your left hand Perfect
all right we're going to get back to
this body cam in a second but I want to
take a minute to talk about something
else that happens all the time workplace
injuries if you get hurt at your job
whether it's a slip and fall a
mechanical failure negligence of your
co-workers something hits you you're
going to need a trusted law firm in your
corner enter Pon Le hockey Giordano a
firm that is a heavyweight in the
industry that wins all different kinds
of injury cases yes workplace but also
accidents Social Security Disability
injuries they have a track record of
recovering over $1 billion for their
clients and they have won over a 100,000
cases they have 250 years of combined
experience how amazing is that so you
can check out ponle hockey Giordano at
ponle hockey.com
/lc bodycam or you can pick up the phone
and call them at 833 669 4043 all right
let's get back to the body cam all right
what we're going to do we're going to
have our feet together arms down by our
side just like this all right when I
tell you two we're going to tilt our
head back and we're going to close our
eyes all right we're going to have our
heel tilted back and eyes closed for the
entire exercise all right once you do
that I will give you I will give you a
series of commands it will either be
left or right all right if I say left I
want you to bring your left index finger
your point finger you're going to bring
it up with the tip of the finger you
touch the tip of the nose all right not
the pad not the bridge tip of the finger
tip of the nose once you touch your nose
you bring it right back in all right if
I say right right index
now just like that all right you have
any questions you understand all right
going tilt your head back close your
eyes
left you got to keep your eyes
closed
right
left
right all right go and relax no
46 you know the English alphabet A to Z
yeah all right what we're going to do
we're going to keep our feet together
arms on by our side just how we were
we're going to be in the same position
we were just in all right we're going to
have a hip tilted back and eyes closed
for the tire exercise all right once you
til you tilt your head back and close
your eyes I'm going to give you the
command begin when you when I say begin
I want you to recite the alphabet
starting with the letter A All the Way
Forward ending with the letter Z okay
all right I want you to say it in a non-
rythmic manner just like this a b c
D all the way through the Z all right I
just don't want to sing the ABC song or
anything all right you understand you
have any questions all right going to
tilt your HP back close your eyes and
you can begin keep your eyes closed for
a b c d e f
g h i g k l n n o p q q r s t u v w x y
n z okay
relax next one I'm going to have you in
the same position all right once you
tilt your head back and close your eyes
I'm going to give you the command begin
when I say begin I want you to count 30
seconds to yourself silently all right
just silently in your head with my with
my head belt uh your head yourp the back
and eyes closed for en tired and I'm
counting myself and you're counting
yourself once I give you the command
begin all right once you think 30
seconds has elapsed I want you to raise
your head up open your eyes and tell me
now okay you have any questions you
understand all right tilch your head
back close your eyes and you can
begin
all
right
and Cooperative all right all I do is
DUI enforcement all right so that's all
I do is is this okay I know you have
alcohol on board I know you had alcohol
tonight okay so I've been lied to
Once how much alcohol have you had
tonight what time is it do you know what
time it is I haven't looked at my phone
10: 12 it's 12 12
something I left I left the Atlantic AB
at 12
12 okay but you didn't go to you said
you went to your mom's house that's
yes and my friends who are visiting from
college have been we went to Atlantic
app that's where I came from my mom's
house I went to Atlantic and I'm driving
to my dad's
house okay so how much alcohol have we
had um my friend s who I was with had a
had a Corona Light and that's all I
drank in I had his Corona Light cuz he
didn't want it that's all I've
had when did you finish that
um it was when we first went out so
probably around like 9:45 10 that's when
you finish it 10 10 10:30 10 around
I I don't I don't think like that I I
will do I will do any tests you
need any other tests you need you
have all right I'm giving you a chance
to be I'm trying to I'm trying to give
you a chance know I know I all right
it's 10 minutes to one yes all right you
say you finished your beer at 10:00
around 10 yeah 10 10 yeah that's 3 hours
roughly yes
okay one beer is not going to put you at
where you're at right now in 3
hours I'm not drunk I'm not
TIY I know that I I don't I do not drink
like that I have had my fair share of
bad bad
um
alcohol whatever you want to call it
drunkness I've had that that I've been
to I just graduated high school last
year and I've been to my bad parties I'm
not drunk my friend can drive for me she
is not drunk she may even have a drink
at all she will tell you that she can
why didn't you let her drive to begin
with she can drive to begin with I I did
not at all think I was under the
influence at all I would never ever ever
put myself in that situation nor my
friend because it's a even my car it's
my dad's
car the only the time I've been pulled
over I got speeding ticket and I'm going
to the Ticket Clinic I have the Ticket
Clinic website and I'm that's why I
thought you pulled me over because I
haven't paid that ticket yet and I was
completely scared I told my friend I was
like Hey girl like that's probably why
I'm being pulled over I did not think me
cutting someone off in the merging was
at all IL
legal being pulled over sces the shit
out of me so she can drive you can do
the same the the test you did with me
with her all right this is what we're
going to do you have to turn around
we're going to go with at
night place under arrest for driving
Under the Influence I'm going to
transport you to West Palm Beach to
request a breath sample to determine
alcohol content all right do you
understand you have anything on you
you're not supposed to
have
all right let's walk back over here to
my get your boots here in a
[Applause]
second you have your phone in the car no
I don't have my phone you don't have a
phone at all no it's in my car that's
why I ask you it's in the car you have
house keys in the car yeah
in my purse she she'll know what my
purse is it's a green purse all right
and um so we're going to get your phone
you have do you have a wallet with your
uh stuff in your purse yeah I have
everything in my purse all right we're
going to get your wallet your phone all
right and keys that's going to go with
you okay so just hang hang tight in here
my dad my dad is out of town okay he's
in Georgia he's in Georgia he can't come
get me all right hang tight okay okay
oh my
[Music]
God
my sorry oh my
God I
[Music]
can't my
God
so I hate
myself
[Music]
I
literally are you kidding me God
you God all I do is pray to you and
you're shit
you're my dad's going to kill
me
my I see it I see I oh
my you want to get C with pour it in
your bag of a cop car you're the back of
the cop car
Avery do you understand do you
understand what the you just
did you're about
[Music]
to
cop
you just got
a you
Avery for what
for
what cuz you wanted to go see your
boyfriend wasn't the shit about you
God
you you're in the back of a you done
nothing your old life but guess what
guess what you want to have two and
guess the what oh my
God I hate
myself God
please God
please dear
God please
[Music]
you all I trying to
do ex-boyfriend's
house I've done
everything
I pass their
stupid I don't know why the even back
here please God
[Applause]
please
[Music]
the po
car oh my
God I have two cats to take care of I
have a dog I'm I need oh my
God oh my
God
please I'm not toxic and I'm not even
halfway there holy shit I just going to
got off on the next
exit oh my
God I have two cats my dad is out of
town my mom fucking hates
me
please please
God please
God God if you hear me if you hear
me
God up
situ
I don't know what the fuck to
do I don't want to go to
jail I don't want to glitch you
God
[Music]
please please I'm a white girl B I can't
go to jail
[Music]
God please
God
please please I'll do anything I'll
never do what I did before I a
job all right Avery are these 10 issues
yours
yeah they're my running shoes okay I'm
going to take these up there with us
instead of the boots okay um that way
you'll be able to wear these while
you're up there
okay oh my God
[Music]
oh my
God oh
my my parents
AR
where's my friend going her mom's coming
to pick her up where's my car going to
be it's going to go to Westway Towing
for safekeeping where's my phone and
everything your phone and your card and
your cash and ID are right here okay
okay I even have your house
okay my dad my dad is out of town can't
get me
h a 1015 white female be a 51 to the bat
you can 45 then let them know 51 and 65
starting it's going to be
64,8 we's going to come pick him up now
that way I'm waiting on toe